[Music]
Milo Ventimiglia said he wasn't the
first choice for the role of veterans
not true Mandy Moore is spilling this is
us bombshell and behind a scene secrets
from her upcoming shark thriller a 47
meters down what I love about it is it's
almost all shot underwater yes what was
the most challenging part about that
everything everything about this movie
yeah we spent a solid eight weeks eight
hours a day underwater so how many hours
is that in water right yeah yeah I feel
like it was far more than that
that was me I don't think either of us
were really prepared for you know
surfacing at lunchtime and being that
bone-tired we both like collapse the
physicality of these roles is insane can
you do anything now that you couldn't do
before this movie I'm like maybe at the
end of it my lung capacity of really
don't have my lung are you my scuba
certified no we're not no matter you
Harriet I'm like Hollywood certified
like we were cause I'm certified we took
like two days Australian and I felt
really Evan I felt so compelled like at
the beginning of our training before we
shot the movie but after the movie I was
like I'm not yeah I'm a little water log
yeah yeah the giddy way Shane was slowly
please sign cater obviously such strong
characters but a lot of actresses have
complained about the lack of strong
female roles in movies do you feel like
with this movie and Wonder Woman at that
shifting a little bit I think we were
very fortunate with this film to be able
to portray strong female characters they
were here as it felt that this all sex
is always been well it's fantastic to
celebrate Wonder Woman and it deserves
all of those accolades but it shouldn't
it shouldn't be such a rare circumstance
another role that everybody loves before
of course Rebecca Pearson and this is us
but you tweeted that were season 2 the
scripts are going to be under lockdown I
read that in an article from our boss he
said that you know next season he's
going to have to like change name so
much interest out there that he he's
like yeah we're gonna have to do things
the secret I'm like oh great I'm going
to be the one that totally like leads my
script somewhere
someone reads it like I trouble well
does that mean people like Claire or
family members or the boyfriend don't
get to sneak one like an audience I have
been very good about not letting people
know but most people don't aren't
curious about that Milo Ventimiglia said
he wasn't the first choice for the role
of hedges not true
it's not so why'd he say that because
he's Milo and he's sweet and has no ego
but when I went in to like test for it
and there was a couple of other guys I
knew going in that he was the one that
they wanted yeah were you the first pick
do you know obviously you must have been
oh no I mean but I mean if you know it's
auditioning for any project is it such a
crapshoot and I just feel lucky that
somehow I lucked out and got to be part
of it
hard to think of Entertainment Tonight
without doing dude it maybe you can
answer your questions in song form
[Music]